I forgot to tell you guys I went to
Harlan Williams nobody remember him a
Harlan Williams is a friend amount of
comedian and he was in the movie and I
feel like I'm name-dropping this whole
episode but he invited me to his
Christmas party and he was in the movie
what is it damn not dancing wolves it
was armed oh oh honey I know Honey I
Shrunk know there's something about
Mary's there's something about Mary's
and I'll say this about Mary's did I
dated a couple in high school and I'll
say this they give some real decent
[__] that's one thing about Mary's I
don't know about what the other stuff is
but so I went there and it's fun man
Harlan's knows how to throw a good party
because everybody brings a 99-cent gift
and man he lives in a fancy place it's
like at the top of the Hollywood Hills
you drive up there and he said damn near
who lived by him
Jodeci lived by him Raven That's So
Raven
you know the bird woman who was in you
know Bill Cosby's you know part of when
he was a doctor and you know and we had
a good time but I accidentally started a
fire I was in the kitchen and they had a
man who was drinking because he he got
to spend time away from his wife and
kids for a night and so he was getting
alcohol and he was drinking a bunch of
wine and his teeth was turning gray and
this man apparently he worked as Kermit
the frog's voice he did Kermit the
frog's voice all in different films or
something we kept talking to me talking
talking and I was trying to kind of lean
I was happy to listen but I was always I
was also trying to just you know be a
part of the scene and he was talking I
think he might have just been kind of
nervous and I was kind of I was a little
bit lonesome I didn't know anybody
really there so you know it was
enjoyable but he kept talking so I was
leaning on the fire on the hose on the
little thing that starts the stove the
igniter
and dude Harlan had about 30 pizzas on
the stove in the box of dominoes next
thing you know bro I guess I hit the
light thing and it lit up and some guy
pushed me kind of out of the way and he
really became a real um Savior he became
a savior and I wasn't being a savior I
was just being somebody that started a
[__] fire I guess but you know I
don't know they say when you know [__]
hits the fan you learn who you are you
know you're either somebody that's
throwing more [__] at the fan or you're
a diaper you're somebody that helps the
situation and I think I think I was just
kind of neither one I just didn't I mean
I cared but also as a psych [__] man
let's add some fire to this [__] son
you know because when you don't drink
and do drugs sometimes you start looking
for the devil and you want to see
sometimes you want to see the dark arts
boy sometime I starve all to Morton baby
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one